a murder investigation is underway after
a woman was shot and killed late on
Christmas Eve at a pub in a merseyside
village she died from her injuries in
hospital at the after the shooting at
the lighthouse in in wallasey Village
three men also suffered gunshot wounds
and a number of other people are said to
have been injured police say they think
the gunman left the car Pub car park in
a dark colored vehicle which might have
been a Mercedes well in samam Rashid is
in while seaforce this morning and what
is the latest in German
well this is now a murder investigation
that merseyside police are undertaking
and it also is an incident where they
are now on The Manhunt for this gunman
it's believed that this gunman uh was
driving a car which left the lighthouse
in just behind me here and fled from the
scene merseyside police now looking for
that person but details about what
happened here very limited to us Dermot
as I mentioned a murder investigation
because at 11 50 last night's Christmas
Eve police received a call following
reports of gunshots it was then a young
woman was taken to hospital
with gunshot wounds it's believed and
then she later died police confirming
that three men were also taken to
hospital with gunshot wounds as well and
a number of others were injured at this
incident uh here last night if I just
step out the way you can actually just
have a look at um the lighthouse in
itself there are still beer bottles
glasses uh the TV still on inside the
pub as well and clearly there is a a
police presence here police tape has
been up since the early hours of this
morning a number of police officers
carrying out investigations here as well
and the street has been cordoned off of
course there would have been a lot of
worry from the residents around this
area plenty of homes around here as well
now what the police said in a statement
early this morning is that this
investigation is in the very early
stages we understand that this is a
truly shocking and devastating incident
that has happened just before Christmas
day in a busy venue full of young people
they went on to say that we believe the
Goodman left the pub car park in dark
colored vehicle possibly a dark colored
Mercedes shortly after the shooting and
we are Keen to hear from anyone who saw
this to contact us immediately as I
mentioned those details still quite
sketchy we're unsure of the the age of
this woman who who um who was killed
last night the ages of the three men who
are currently with gunshot wounds and
exactly how many other people had been
injured at the scene here last night so
those details quite minimal but clearly
a heavy police presence now a murder
investigation and a Manhunt to try and
find that gunman who attacked people
here last night